oh [__]
let's get this party started right
[__]
[Music]
greetings you bad [__] welcome
to periscope ville it's a beautiful day
to be alive here in Southern California
the sun's out the birds are chirping
you're alive you got nutsack juice in
there you're ready to [__] go you
just need a little push to get you out
the [__] door that's where Joey comes
in smoking today on fire we got a great
show last night for 20 but today is for
21 [__]
and that's all that matters you still
gotta [__] and keep up the [__]
appearance if you're gonna be a soldier
we got some tremendous weed I got this
presidential food [__] sunset herb
the home of the stars and you know me I
got the sour [__] diesel from
perennial crippling [__] on a daily
basis you understand me
people walk in there limping they come
out in a wheelchair that's the type of
reefer they got but cool see Kunsan were
here
it's Friday we made it through another
[__] week the Koreans can't light a
[__] firecracker ain't nobody else
[__] with us
so we're good you know I'm saying you
could relax you to smoke reefer you can
give mama stamina and eat her [__]
without looking over your shoulder every
five minutes you turn around there's
some [__] do dare stand there with a
hat saluting themself anyway enough with
the chitter chatter
are you going blow out the negativity
too [__] old hair that's fart that
stuck under your rib blow it out with
this [__] we fill and get your day
started right I don't know if you yet
work I don't think your [__] lunch
time I don't know what the [__] you're
doing tell everybody you suck your dick
this is uncle Joey time this is where
Joey and me smoke the reefer a debt and
we got our heads together and it makes
it easier to make the day go by [__]
smooth you understand me let's try some
of this [__] oh [__] direct from
[__] the one I jus this is the weed
that [__] up Dickie sigh at last night
it [__] me up before I went on stage
how much smoking good refill hello from
the reef of sneaks up on you like two
[__] euro Merrill me and I'm saying
I'll send you sitting there you got that
white [__] on the side of your mouth
that's when you know you're [__]
stoned to the gills
look at that [__] beautiful
[__] beautiful but that's it and
that's that I got two shows on Oxnard
tonight you got nothing to do swing by
if you're in Santa Barbara Vancouver the
[__] you live come on by it's a nice
facility they got a [__] restaurant
couple restaurants they got a movie
theater they got a target which is
always useful on the way [__] home
and you come you laugh you smoke some
reefer you have a good time we giggle
that's it but what else you want to do
sit in front of the TV and life is
[__] short Spicer the chick place
that's so funny I loved when Alec
Baldwin does Trump get the [__] out of
my face
that's the cooler you should have ever
seen in my [__] life what is wrong
with you [__] people as Americans the
[__] oh my goodness my longest [__]
went fiddle battle you understand me and
not from seeing some [__] chick make
it from this [__] reefer that's what
it's all about sometimes everybody wants
to drink everybody wants to jump up and
down on the weekends and dip listen
smoke some reefer stay home get a
notebook and figure out what the [__] is
your next move you understand me
a man without a plan is not a man your
next move is [__] lethal and that's
what comes out when you smoke a little
reefer maybe do 10 20 jumping jacks and
you're ready to [__] go
oh my god I love it is my favorite time
of day
it's smoking away from you Carson look
at me I'm like a weed conductor you [__]
my little shish kebab stick it's a bad
[__] right that thing goes to
[__] hell
everybody else has [__] all these
Pope is to be cool
I got a shish kebab stick I can stick it
in the pipe and then stick it in your
[__] eyeball you'll be stoned for a
month you understand me tremendous you
people that watch periscope that came up
to me after the show last night I love
you [__] - thank you for
watching the periscope is all we have
this is our lethal line of communication
and [__]
the feds are watching but who gives a
[__] they've been watching fees but I
got the wind doing nothing was smoking
some reefer talking Platt my [__]
next movie like [__] Fidel when he
took those bearded [__] into
the mountains and they plotted their
next move and I said man is that [__]
simpler but he thinks that there's a
[__] magic to this listen keep doing
what you're doing every day keeps
showing up if you believe it in your
heart it's gonna happen I don't care if
you want to be a [__] that
rollerskates on your [__] big [__]
head if that's what you want to do you
do it [__] will start on Olympics and
there you are you'll be a roller skating
your little legs are upside down what
are you gonna do at least you having a
good [__] time
we think should we smoke another Tecate
[__] yeah [__] you think you're dealing
with some [__] novice might having
that's so high on that blueberry train
poop I retrieve this suck my dick and so
can the rest of your mother from is this
is the weed that killed [__] having
an end of [__] yeah I'm saying
this is it rest in peace prints you bad
[__] IRA big launch to know what
you died of you died of genius that's
when he [__] died up don't worry
about the pills ever he wants to throw
poison on the [__] guy who gives a
[__] it's like Michael Jackson they died
a genius and it's so high up there they
haven't [__] come down to balance it
out and sometimes you know what the
other do you guys do a little H you got
hire a black doctor to shoot you with
profe and all whatever the [__] they had
them who gives a [__]
the most important thing is that way he
and God gave us another day and we got
to figure out how we're gonna swing dick
on that day that's it
look at that my lung feels [__]
dynamic but anyway I love you guys I'll
see you next week on the podcast we got
two great shows I'd be at Bakersfield
I'll be able to score Tuesday night you
don't me dog I'm a man of many [__]
venues I'll be at the ice house Saturday
night early sharp around next week so if
you need to get ahold of me let's
[__] make this happen [__] if
not I'll see you guys be good keep your
eyes open Isis is around you know that I
just kind of [__] stand there let
them smack us around they got some
[__] people jump in the wall right
now trying to get us but who gives a
[__] you're prepared you ain't looking
like you're falling like a [__] look
what happened last night on TV who gives
a [__] you keep your eyes open concept
it's Friday
anything could happen down the [__]
Mickey Mouse Club I love you guys see
you Monday ready to [__] I'll see you
Sunday morning we'll smoke a joint for
Jesus I usually don't said it's two
weeks since he got out of the cave he's
ready to [__] go I love you
[__] stay black stay strong and
don't let nobody [__] with you today
it's your world they just [__]
visiting you understand me
bye